You know to me, it's interesting the way news... the way this business is shaping now.
I mean, especially in cable news, it seems like,...
what's popular right now is opinion,...
...and having a strong opinion, and yelling about it, or wearing it on your sleeve,...
...and sort of cramming it down viewers' throats.
I personally don't have any interest in that.
I don't think,...
...anchors' opinions are frankly all that interesting...
...or any more interesting than anybody else's opinion.
And I just don't believe in...
...wearing my opinion on my sleeve, and...
...sort of slanting news based on what I think, or yelling about it, and yelling down...
...people who are on the show.
I do believe in walking in other people's shoes...
...and try to look at things from as many different angles as possible.
And, I don't think there should be a Republican newscaster or Democratic newscaster...
...or a Liberal newscaster, and a Conservative newscaster.
There are facts and I think...
...our job is to hold people accountable on all sides and to,...
...you know, find out what the facts are and present the facts.
I mean viewers are smart enough to make up their own minds.